et je te sens triste clown dit je te
sens bien je dois taper chaudoy wattao -
galoche à 1h31 je peux le dire
charles là il ya eu un bail je suis sûr
et certain on fait également ça va mon
chalet il est comme ça il y fit savoir
mon charles 25 ans alors tu étais venu
le voir tu avais jamais couché avec une
fille et je t'avais dit attends tu me
charles quoi franchement tu étais était
prêt à tenter des beaux gosses est à
l'essai un peu plus pousser la barbe
un petit peu plus ce nouveau style bien
mais un no style passe passe demain je
vois ce que je vais faire je vais
égalisé tout ça bon alors tourner ou au
charme je fais rencontre d'une chine
grâce à l'émission du coup on a
rencontré une meuf grâce à l'émission
n'ont commencé mais dans le public
non non pendant qu'il est lent mais
c'est pas eric woerth c'est
l'anniversaire aujourd'hui
l'émission dure sept heures c'est son
anniversaire hier parce qu'il leur est
d'ailleurs en fin d'émission lors un
petit cadeau pour toi
ah oui aux petits cadeaux donc non non
c'est pas n'était pas non plus lui qui
s'est passé après l'émission il a été
contacté par une fille qui cherchait à
me contacter pour trois jours sur
facebook
alalalala chercher ton profil pendant
trois jours sur facebook aol était
motivée de ouf motivé ah ouais et donc
elle tint kalt à contacter apt a dit
quoi la niche débuts dans l'émission
balances ton post début on a parlé 20
minutes ou téléphone le précité 5 heures
et après 5 heures 5 heures hôtel - ah
ouais tu l'a pas revu non ces juges mais
tu vas l'avoir je la vend ce truc à nous
non on va mettre des caméras est la
grande rade comme ça mais je n'avais pas
et qui ne sont pas les seuls alors je te
le dis là est fracturé à spa la barbe ça
te va très bien au niveau de la chemise
on est parfait c'est très content de ce
que tu as mis là le petit pantalon j'ai
vu le petit pantalon
non non les ponts les choses sur tout et
bien là car nouveau style aussi toi
nouveau inquiets dans le jeu plus
confiance en moi grâce à deux sauts et
bien alors et tu es ce que tu avais une
photo d'elle ou pas oui elle te plaît
william plus l apanage 24 ah ouais tu as
les yeux qui brillent s'affaiblira je te
jure ah ouais tu es là tu es comment
foule ce week-end vous allez faire quoi
on va justement d'avoir se rencontrer
devant d'accord l'ucla on va prendre un
petit verre tranquille c'est ça d'accord
l'habitat ce loin d'ici à bittou x100
pense mais c'est en france avec s'en
prendre à quelle heure vous prenez le
vert le matin l'après midi on ne sait
pas où l'on regarde je crois que vous
prenez un petit des eaux mais peut-être
non mais c'est pas exactement à paris
non non c'est comme une souris donc
c'est ce qui va peser sur qui vaille
c'est moi qui veux tu vas dire
mais voilà ah oui je m'adresse à genève
si j'étais toi et karim est d'accord
avec moi j'aurais joué à domicile mais
bon non non il va dans la plus belle
région de france celle autour d'une
journée
as-tu fait l'aller retour dans la
journée ah ouais très hâte en motivation
extrême à l'aller retour dans les yeux
je la sens bien cette affaire est celle
qu est ce que ça te plaît beaucoup est
ce que tu peux rester là bas voilà on
verra comment ça se passe ça prenait 0,4
paris avec 5 trop vite les gens comme
moi à peu près un mois
oui il est comme moi lui je le vois tout
de suite ils n'aiment pas que ça va trop
vite
c'est vrai le web direct line bas il
veut aller faire d'abord connaissance
comprendre qu'il est en principe le co
voilà on rentre à la maison alors les
affinités avec huawei c'est très bien en
tout cas été heureux et a eu d'autres
moments doux que cette fille là j'ai eu
de demande mais j'ai pas aimé c'est sur
elle que tu es sérieux
ah ouais non mais jamais monsieur 10 en
tout cas elle a de la chance et sérieux
j'espère qu'elle est bien parce que les
garçons comme ça et un beau coup c'est
la contacter c'est qu'elle était elle
elle a déjà eu des relations avec des
garçons bah oui oui après je ne dirai
pas plus l'accord valorise ne veux pas
que tu dois je peux aussi te flinguer le
maillot ça se fait pas à cause de moi je
m'en voudrais honte avait trouvé très
courageux en fait de témoigner parce que
de dire ça comme ça publiquement tu
regrettes ou pas du tout juste d'être
dévoilée t'as pas eu de retour négatif
non pas du tout non mais attends il est
à deux doigts de pécho là notamment chat
et j'ai l'impression bras je voulais
mettre cette histoire elle peut aller
très loin
et est-ce qu'on va pas avoir le premier
mariage de balance mon poste
ouais
super jure t - il faut que je rentre et
on doit rentrer sur ferron studio ce
organisé le mariage barman
d'associations tu me laisses faire
franchement je peux faire l'animation
également je te mets sur une chaise
frère je te fais ce faire qu'il fait je
veux un mariage ou à la copro je veux ta
mére du rivage qui arrive aux
montgolfières vous vous télescoper les
traiteurs mais des sandwiches ou jamais
de larissa comme ça tout va
c'est comme ça je t'ai d'harissa pour
les invités et bill tu veux ou pas j'ai
l'impression qu'il est plus est en tout
cas je suis très heureux pour toi
heureusement charles hey tu me tiens au
courant mais je te tient encore bon et
était confiant confiance mais en tout
cas je te le dis airbus compte avait dit
à la fois c'est que effraie grave mais
jamais ça n'en fraîcheur de vivre en
hollywood chewing gum toi et je te lis à
trouver ton stin non mais c'est vrai si
mich icmi des contrats tu vois